kourtney kardashian's ex eunice benjamin
is calling out her other ex scott disick
over an alleged direct message he claims
he received from the father of three it
all went down monday night after the 28
year old model who dated court on and
off for years prior to her current
relationship with travis barker took to
his insta stories to share a screenshot
of some dms he claims are from scott the
alleged post includes a pick of courtney
straddling travis while kissing him on
their current italian vacation and the
message allegedly sent by scott reads
quote yo is this chick okay
bro like what is this in the middle of
italy eunice's response quote doesn't
matter to me as long as she's happy p.s
i ain't your bro eunice added a note to
the screenshot writing quote keep the
same energy you had about me publicly
privately but he wasn't done eunice
added another slide writing couldn't
miss this one he'd been playing around
for too long tried to stay quiet and be
the nice guy et has reached out to
courtney scott and eunice for comment of
course scott as well as several other
members of the pooch founders family
expressed some dislike for eunice during
the keeping up with the kardashians
reunion special back in june it seems
like you get really upset when courtney
is linked to other guys
me
yeah no no no oh do you want to kill
them
what did you say he said i just want to
kill them you just want to kill them
okay okay is he equal the last guy let's
all be honest nobody was happy with the
last one really yeah scott and everyone
else
i was still there to try to help during
that same special scott gave courtney
his blessing to be happy in her new
relationship with a blink 182 drummer i
think if you really love somebody right
like you want them to be happy no matter
what
so i do give her a blessing to be happy
meanwhile a source tells e.t scott has
always been a little salty and upset
about court's current relationship quote
he doesn't love thinking or talking
about it he tries to focus on his own
life as much as possible but sometimes
it feels like it's in his face and hard
to avoid seeing courtney and travis get
more and more serious and her move on in
this intense way has been a bit of a
sore subject as for court and travis the
source adds that they are unbothered by
everything and in their own little
bubble
[Music]